nobody's gonna know they're gonna know
how would they know
[Music]
ouch demi lovato reveals a serious face
injury but at least they're a good sport
about it
absolutely
demi shows off the gnarly bruise right
above their eyebrow on tick-tock and you
can see them visibly dropping the f-bomb
in the video
how would they know
we get why the singer seems frustrated
demi explains the timing couldn't be
worse right before their late night
appearance on jimmy kimmel live demi
wrote in the caption guess who hit their
head on a crystal and has to get
stitches before kimmel tomorrow
nobody's gonna know they're gonna know
yeah even with makeup covering the
injury seems like they're gonna know how
would they know
of course demi's appearance on kimmel is
in support of their return to rock music
they dropped the lead single off their
upcoming album skin of my teeth last
month
[Music]
and this all comes on the heels of
demi's return to the spotlight after
years of battling addiction
and breaking up with my old self and my
addiction and my alcoholism
over the years sobriety's been a goal
for demi the 29 year old told jimmy
fallon last month they finally achieved
it while working on this new album
titled holy
out august 19th after going through even
more stuff last year um i came out of
treatment again
and i
realized like
i really want to do this for myself and
i want to make the best album possible i
made this album you know clean and sober
i can't say that about my last album but
this one i'm really really proud about
and good news for lovatics demi is also
set to go on tour
[Applause]
fans can expect to hear that song during
the live show as well as demi's second
single substance which they teased on
tick tock ahead of its july 15 release
me the real fish give me the magic demi
can't contain her excitement you know my
music is growing and i feel really
excited and i can't wait for my fans to
hear new music keep it coming demi just
please avoid any more mishaps they're
gonna know
how would they know
[Music]
you